nfc win totals courtesy of our friends
at points bet they came out over this
weekend and let's take a look at some of
these beginning with
the nfc south and this is these are not
based on
a seven are they based on 17 are not
based on of course they are
that is the dumbest question you've
asked in our lives
are they basing this on the season that
we're going to play this year are they
going to base it off
a fake number of games they might play
this year here's what happens here's
what happens when someone's talking to
you while you're talking sometimes
things aren't clear and i was alarmed
it's like wait a minute they're not
based on a 17 game season
maybe they came out before the season
went to 17.
these are based on 17. thank you all
right
buccaneers based on a 17 game season in
the nfc
south 11 and a half is the win total
so that would project to 11 and a half
and five and a half under a 17 game
season
new orleans only nine which i guess
makes sense with drew brees now retired
carolina at seven and a half
atlanta at seven again this is all based
on a 17
game season because the season will now
be 17
games i it's it's weird to get used to
that
you know you you just automatically see
11 and 11 and a half and you think oh
okay
will they be 11 and five or 12 and four
this is gonna take some like total
mental juggling here to get used to this
but like
i mean again i look at the bucks at 11
and a half
with that team an extra game all that i
mean yeah i
i look at that right off the bat and
just go they're going to win more than
11 and a half 11 and a half games i i'd
be
i'd be surprised if they didn't i know
it's never easy
as a super bowl winner defending
champion
all of those type of things but also
it's like
we've talked about it before you bring
it up all the time i mean they got guy
like brady there
who's gonna you know keep a hot poker
next to everybody's butt so they're on
their p's and q's
and i think it's a team that's like it's
it it just kind of started to come
together
at the end of the year i mean really it
was the last few games in the playoffs
to where
them winning and being dominant i think
is kind of new to the team there to
where
i do expect them to have a jump off here
and kind of hit the ground running when
when we start the 2021 season
there are factors that go into this and
and obviously
who you play yeah right is one of the
big factors
the divisions that you play how the
schedule plays out this year
and they've got this year the teams
of the nfc east which should
fatten things up a little bit and also
the teams of the afc east which
that division will be more difficult
that was last year but that's conducive
to all the teams of the nfc
south maybe winning more games than
otherwise would
and then that crossover game that one
extra game is buccaneers
at the indianapolis colts in 2021
but you know the other side of it too
chris and and i suspect these numbers
will change throughout the remainder of
the off season right
betting trends will be part of it but
once we know
exactly what the schedule is when will
the difficult games be played
will you have a chance to come out of
the gates against some
easier opponents and build some momentum
and fatten up your record and carry that
into october november december that's a
very real factor yeah
every year there's a team out there that
gets an easy start
to the season and builds confidence and
then we'll see what they do with it
sometimes they get exposed later when
they get to the tougher part of the
schedule
sometimes they're better prepared for
the tougher part of the schedule
because they've managed to win games
early and they feel better about
themselves especially with a new coach
you get a new coach and an easy schedule
you get guys to buy into what the coach
is doing definitely
and you're in a better position to beat
those good teams no i it is the
to me that's the real aspect when you
talk about like you know the the
the future year that you're looking at
it's that's that first four or five
games when you talk about schedule
that's why i always laugh when like i
see people on tv like
here's week 16 in december
i'm going to give them a win even though
i don't know how many guys will be
healthy on their team or that team or
anything like that
you know yeah it is yeah i think that's
the point mike that you make it's about
what you got
early on in the year does that give you
a cushion
is it gonna put you in the hole to where
you're gonna have to battle back you
know either way
tampa you look at the roster you go
there's nothing
that they don't have it's a special
roster i think the the thing i
question i think with anything there in
the nfc south a little bit is yeah
we know the saints are a question mark
it's no drew brees for a long time
how good are they going to be i think we
would both agree we still think they're
going to be
real good in the playoff conversation
type good
i'm not going to sit here and say
they're a definite play-off team but i
would be shocked if they're not flirting
with that
the other thing too is just i'm taking
the over on that one i'm sorry
i i mean i'm not i'm not betting on any
of these right if anyone out there wants
some free advice you're going
to get your money's worth bet the over
on the saints at nine are you kidding me
i would think so too
there's no doubt i mean with 17 games
17. that's
that's a nine and eight record they're
not going to be nine and eight they're
gonna be ten and seven at least
now watch they'll be six and eleven well
it's to be hard to get used to
it really is it well here's the other
thing too just you know as far as tampa
is concerned when we talk about them
you know i would expect carolina and
atlanta to be a different football team
this year too
i mean we know atlanta has some talent
and
you know now you got the new coaching
energy bump like you're talking about
there's that
carolina the same way we'll see what
they do at quarterback of course that
could affect some of these wins totals
and everything like that too
but i would think as a whole just as a
as a totality in the nfc south
the one negative the bucks have is i
think the division will be
better this year you know that's where i
think you're not going to just be able
to go
okay carolina we're going to beat them
twice atlanta we're gonna beat them
twice
there's four wins bam we're good i think
it could be a little more dicey this
year
uh as far as those teams are concerned
yeah i mean i agree uh i agree with what
you're saying about the south but
remember it's always a zero-sum game
there's
only so many games played and there's a
winner and a loser for every game and
the one thing that
you'll see in addition to people
trying to pick winners of games to be
played in late december and we know that
always happens
the night the schedule comes out that's
part of what that three-hour show on all
the networks that have the three-hour
show is devoted to
you also have the one loss records that
when you add it up
across all teams it's more wins than
losses right
because we're not taking into account
the fact that people will be losing
these games in addition to winning these
games nfc west
toughest division in football san
francisco and la
tied at 10 and a half
again based on a 17 game season
tied at 10 and a half seattle at nine
and a half
arizona at eight um are you surprised
i seems yeah i i'm surprised la's not
alone i'm surprised la's not number one
i
i
mean i am too i guess i'm surprised that
san francisco is right there at 10 and a
half just neck and neck with them
you know i i get it being close but you
know like we talked about the first hour
first off we don't even know
if jimmy g or who the quarterback is for
the 49ers yet that's where i guess i'm a
little surprised
yeah i i mean i think the team is
talented but i'm with you
the nfc west it's really i mean you look
at it
and you look at those four teams there
and you go all right well two of them
we're not sure those are gonna be the
quarterbacks in five weeks i mean
there's
we we still think there's a chance
russell wilson gets traded out of
seattle
and who the hell knows what happens here
with the san francisco 49ers the number
three pick
so uh i think that's the amazing thing
about the division let alone it's like
incredibly talented and the team at the
top like you're talking about the rams
i'm with you i think they should
probably be alone
but man they're a team that i'll go back
to it again
it's like one or two injuries on that
team and you go watch out they're gonna
be in trouble they're so top-heavy
there's no depth to their football team
so i'm excited about them but i do worry
about them from that aspect
all right 49ers 10 and a half and we
don't know who the quarterback is going
to be
what would you have the number at if you
knew it was going to be jimmy g
and what would you have the number at if
you knew it was going to be rookie
taking third overall oh wow
what would the spread be ooh that that's
a really good question
um okay so i mean you're assuming yeah
i guess i guess i would feel better
about jimmy g as far as overall
record things are gonna be like that i
do think maybe there's a chance for
just off the top of my head of the 49ers
offense reaching a higher level with
maybe one of these young quarterbacks at
type
at pick number three you know yeah
listen i'm intrigued by the athleticism
of guys like field and lance i don't
think they're number three picks in the
draft
i do think mac jones might be able to do
some matt ryan type stuff
but it's hard for me to sit there and
just take a rookie and say his win total
is going to be better than a jimmy
garoppolo who plays a whole year
so i guess we're i don't think it's a
huge difference
where i'll go like okay rookie year
quarterback versus jimmy garoppolo
i'm gonna go jimmy garoppolo gets 11
wins
maybe 11 and a half type of like
where the rookie i'm gonna go to you
know i'm gonna set the bar at like nine
and a half
maybe ten right there i'm gonna give
jimmy g at least an extra win for sure
over a rookie quarterback i am see i
i think it should be tight because it's
the shanahan offense yeah so it's not
going to matter in my mind quarterback
is right
i don't see a huge spread there another
reason that
maybe this is why the 49ers and the rams
are equal yeah because of that 17th game
and because of the natural spread in
where you finish
the rams this year will be facing
at some point the ravens in baltimore
as the 17th game for the 49ers
it's a trip to cincinnati to play the
bengals right so
that's one where you see a more likely
win for the 49ers
than for the rams and also across the
division they play all the teams
of the nfc north and all the teams
of the afc south and also also
rams will play the buccaneers this year
49ers because of where they finished in
the division will play the falcons
instead
so you know there are now three games
of the 17 that are tied to where you
finish it used to be two now there's
three
right and four for the rams two of those
games are buccaneers ravens and those
two games corresponding for the 49ers
are bengals and falcons and that's
that's a reason to explain why
10 and a half is the number for both
teams yeah no you're right i mean you
gotta you got to think about that aspect
a little bit now you're right with that
extra game that extra crossover game
with the the afc football team
uh that that thought has to go through
your brain definitely i mean
yeah we don't know how that works out
but sitting here right now in april
at base level you're right that seems
advantage 49ers there and at least those
two football games we'll see where the
rest goes but man
what an unbelievable division i mean we
got two teams
we got two teams with like
quarterbacks we can't wait to see what
happens and we got two other teams where
we don't know what the hell is going to
happen at quarterback and one of them
has one of the five best quarterbacks in
the game
it's just the talent of the this
division
is up there with anybody and uh man
good defensive play you know matt
stafford in los angeles how can you not
be excited about that
the cardinals have improved their
football team this offseason
you know with getting j.j watts you know
trading for rodney hudson doing that
so i i mean i'm really excited to see
how it shakes out there
that really is quite a dip though for
the seahawks and it shows that at least
the betting markets for now don't have a
lot of faith in shane waldron
as the new offensive coordinator getting
more out of that team
they were 12 and four last year and the
division champions
and uh the idea that they're going to
dip to that extent
is surprising to me but uh but again we
don't even know who the quarterback is
going to be that's what makes
these these numbers even more
speculative at this point because of the
fact that there's still a lot of off
season to go
a lot of moves can we make this is all
pre-draft yeah these numbers will change
and not just because of betting trends
they're going to change because there
will be developments and changes in the
roster and
we're going to feel differently about
these teams especially if the seahawks
would end up trading
russell wilson but premised upon them
having russell wilson
i would expect that number to be higher
than nine and a half yeah do you think
there's an adjustment
made there after the draft is over just
because of that do you think if he's not
traded
yeah right like if he's not traded and
now they're like okay that's off the
table he's definitely gonna be there
you know now we can bump them up another
win because we weren't sure
you know before this where he was gonna
be but now you know
i would think that gives him another
half game if we get out of the draft and
he's not traded
that that gets bumped up a little bit i
would think
i think it will i think if he's still on
the team after the draft that number
definitely moves up just because beyond
anything else
i think people would would pounce on the
over
on nine and a half if it stays at nine
and a half after the draft and russell
wilson is still on the team
nfc north packers 13-3 in 2020
13-3 in 2021 there's the win total
premised on a 17-game season
10 and a half i know right again kind of
pops out 17 games
confirmed yet again this is based on a
17 game season that one does jump out
right being surprisingly low
i agreed i i just think you look at that
i think the the big thing just like
again right off the bat is just to go
i i don't know i mean is there anybody
that we really view as a serious threat
to the packers and that division sitting
here right now
i mean maybe the bears i mean maybe but
i i i
again i'm not ready to sit here and go
oh minnesota's ready to challenge i'm
not ready to say that yet
i think they'll be good can be a pain in
the butt i don't know if they're ready
to like
be an nfc north challenger for the
championship there
the lions i certainly don't expect that
so that's where it's like 17 game
season 10 and a half wins aaron rodgers
playing awesome football i mean that's
one right now where i
if i was a betting person i would i
would throw money on that right now and
get it for the low
the teams of the afc north will be
played by the teams of the nfc north all
four of them across the board
and also the teams of the nfc
west so it will not be an easy season
that's made for the nfc
north teams right and and packers extra
game
at kansas city vikings extra game
at the la chargers that's another one
that that is going to be tied to where
you finished and the packers reward for
being
the first place team in the nfc north is
pack up and go to arrowhead
stadium at some point and potentially
take an l from patrick mahomes and
company so i think that's a factor
the vikings at eight and a half strike
me as low simply because we know the
formula by now the roller coaster under
mike zimmer
odd number years you get to the playoffs
even number of years
you don't and they've they've bumped up
that defense to the point where
zimmer is feeling rejuvenated although
the pass rush still needs some help
and they still don't have a replacement
for riley reef at left tackle other than
that everything's fine for the vikings
but
i could see them with fans present
however many are in the stands
that's a different dynamic for the
vikings this year i think one of the
reasons they got knocked wobbly last
year
is they didn't have a home field
advantage and that really did
hamper them in multiple games i you you
add fans
you give them a little bit of an easier
schedule you improve that defense
i'm not saying they're ready to
challenge the packers as the champions
of the division
but i think they're they're in a
position super bowl
super bowl no no wild card birth
and maybe a wild card win and then a
loss by 20 in the divisional round
that's the best case scenario
but that's still more than eight and a
half wins in a 17 game season yeah
no i mean yes i i i could see that type
of scenario i mean
and and it's you know your hashtag
science formula there with odd years so
it means that they're going to be better
yes definitely
uh what do you feel about your team i
mean what do you think have you done
enough here in free agency to make
yourself feel a little bit better about
where you guys are going
wild card birth maybe a win in the wild
card round
lost in the division around by 20 points
that's my position
that's that's until further notice
that's my position in the odd numbered
years in the even numbered years it's no
playoffs at all that's the history i can
only
rely on history and that's the trend the
vikings have developed how about detroit
with
five that's the lowest of any team
that's on the board the texans
are off the board for a variety of
reasons the most important of which is
they don't know who their quarterback's
going to be
but the lions know it's going to be
jared goff and
5 and 12 is the projected record and i
don't know that i would touch the over
on that one chris well there's
definitely questions i mean you know
first off you just want to go yeah
there's jared goff at quarterback that's
a question
you know yeah dan campbell certainly
different as far as a head coach is
concerned how's that gonna work out
you know so there's that aspect they've
changed over a lot of their football
team
you look at their offense and you go
okay wait who's
who's the driving force who who's the
go-to guy
galaday's not there marvin jones is gone
deandre swift showed some promise
certainly as a rookie
can hawkinson become that guy i mean i
just think there's a ton of questions
and that goes for the defense too you
flip it over there
and you just go okay is okuda gonna pop
out and year two was the number three
pick he was a little disappointing last
year after that
you know who was there that's a big time
play maker in the secondary we had these
discussions last week
the front seven you know they've
overplayed trey flowers he's a good
player but he's being paid like he's one
of the top edge rushers in football
he's not that you know they got okwara
who they resigned who
showed some promise off the edge i don't
know but there's just lack of like
big time difference makers play makers
and then i think you add
that to new coaches and questioning
maybe their approach
i get it i understand why five is is
associated with their name yeah i i have
no faith in the lions this year and
uh maybe the dan campbell kneecap biting
style
bites your knees will make a difference
here we go
uh but but uh we'll see hey look
everything they've tried for 60 years
has failed so they're trying something
new
okay it can't be any worse than what
we've seen
it's been 30 years since they've won a
playoff game for crying out loud
so different is positive different is
good
maybe eventually they'll stumble into a
style that will work for the detroit
lions and they'll actually win some
football games but even then
given the trade of matthew stafford the
assets they're getting in return it just
feels like they're building for
something down the road that they're not
really trying to go
all in now and if they end up being good
this year great
great that that just accelerates their
potential to be better in 2022
or 23. i feel like there's a tear down
now
with a build-up coming in the future and
they very well could be
3 and 14 this year that still sounds so
weird
3 and 14 but laying the foundation to be
to be better faster than they've ever
been yeah no i think it's it's
it's the right move they they gotta you
know rip the band-aid off here this is
not one where it's like you know
hey we're gonna put a new band-aid on
and a little more neosporin
and we'll figure out how to get this
thing better as we go no
there's nothing to get better you know
it needs a total teardown rebuild all of
that makes sense so
uh you know i'm excited to see what they
do there in detroit
nia sporan way better than merthyalate
which is definitely definitely that
old-timer
old man oh it was this nasty stuff there
were two types
mercurichrome and merthyalate this was
pre-neosporin
play the music i don't care you cut
yourself
when you're a kid right and it was this
nasty s
like it stained your skin orange right
and and
and the mercure chrome did not burn
the merthylate was awful it burned it
like burned out the bacteria
and it was great thank you great thank
you is that what what kind of is that a
victrola
back in your day so uh so anyway
nfc east win totals thank you very much
dallas it's always doubts why is the
paper it's always down
it's always it's always dallas vegas and
then they play the games and it's not
yeah nine and a half right i don't
that's that's what jumps out to me is
just go dallas like just
hands down a game and a half better than
everybody else in the division
why what the hell have they done to
improve their football team
yeah they'll have dak prescott back not
at 100
to start the year i mean their defense i
know they got dan quinn and i expect it
to be approved but there's still nothing
there where i just go oh that defense is
going to turn it around
watch out it's special there's talent
there they were just misused
i don't get that one i really don't as i
sit here in the nfc east right now
and you know you could throw out the
divisions and things they're going to
play
i just look at washington and go wow how
can you not like
everything about their roster i know
there's the ryan fitzpatrick the
question there
i think it fits how they want to play
and what they want to do so
yeah i'm shocked by dallas a game and a
half over these other teams there's no
way
washington and new york are every bit
the quality of dallas and i think in a
lot of ways i look at their team than
their complete roster and go
i think washington new york's rosters
are better than the dallas cowboys
other than wide receiver that's it
the giants seem low to me at seven i
think they really do
yeah and and and also the eagles seem
way too high at six and a half i
i don't know that i would go out and
wager my hard-earned money on the under
just yet
but the six and a half seems optimistic
for a team
that like the lions feels like it's in
the early
stages of a tear down rebuild and the
tear down
means you're going to lose games you're
it's unavoidable
you're going to lose games in 2021 and
six and a half to me seems very
optimistic
yeah i i i i agreed i i that's another
one that's
like you're saying the lions it's it's a
rebuild let's rip the band-aid off we
have a lot of work to do here
all together i mean again nfc is going
to be interesting
you know how good are they going to be i
don't know
you know but the one thing that just
pops out too with this whole like
schedule and everything like that i mean
man we we could definitely end up seeing
you know an eight and nine football team
we could have some underwhelming
schedules get in the playoffs here again
with the 17 games
you could especially in a division like
the nfcs this year
you know just with them being very equal
they could beat each other up
play some cross cross conference and
division
teams that way lose those and all of a
sudden we're sitting there i wonder how
the nfl would feel about that if they
start to look at teams going below 500
in the playoffs every year i don't think
it's necessarily a great look
the nfc east plays all four teams of the
afc
west and all four teams of the nfc
south which means every team in the
worst division in football
will play both the buccaneers
and the kansas city chiefs in 2021 which
yes will make a bad division
even worse and i think that at the end
of the day
the nfl is just going to deal with it if
there's a division that has a team
that's below
500 because the owners do not want to
give up
that one in four shot of hosting a
playoff game under the current
structure and in any given year in
theory
you've got a 25 chance of winning your
division and
hosting a playoff game they're not going
to change that structure yeah right and
they're not going to get away from the
current configuration of teams
unless and until there are more teams
added which i still think is coming at
some point down the line
in order to help build inventory
tomorrow we'll take a look at the afc
team
win totals as projected by points bet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports